[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire où nous
parlons des sujets qui font l'actualité
le 8 mars est la journée internationale
des droits des femmes une journée pour
sensibiliser à l'égalité femmes hommes
un coup de projecteur mais l'accès au
droit c'est 365 jours par an et nos
invités pour ce numéro sont investis
dans cette question bénédicte alico in
bonsoir
bonsoir vous être un gros test vous êtes
adjointe au maire en charge de la
culture notamment à guyancourt clarisse
gorce bonsoir bon voire vous êtes chef
de projet emploi à face yvelines anne
laure carreau bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
directrice du cidff des yvelines c'est
le centre d'information sur le droit des
femmes et des familles et meriem ennjimi
bon soir au moustoir vous êtes
directrice de l'association la nouvelle
étoile à saint rémy les chevreuse anor
40 j'aimerais des goûters avec vous ce
que le cidff est un lieu
d'accompagnement d'information sur les
droits notamment ceux des femmes des
problématiques qui sont encore
importantes en 2022 vous êtes souvent
sollicités
mais on était
à 50 permanente très content et on
reçoit énormément de fans
en droit de la famille droit du travail
donc oui et encore oui
c'est pas seulement le 8 mars j'imagine
alors souvent dans le droit des dents
les droits des femmes on parle beaucoup
de l'accès à l'emploi les femmes
représentent 48% de la population active
en france 83% des femmes entre 25 et 49
ans étaient actives en emploi ou chômage
en 2010 7 97% des hommes ce sont souvent
des temps partiel des emplois place à
bas salaires clarisse gorce à face
yvelines les femmes font partie des
personnes les plus accompagné où on est
dans moitié moitié
ont dit vraiment maintenant une place en
effet moi qui vous étiez c'est vrai je
veux tel calcul un peu pour cette
réunion oui on est on a
depuis janvier 2021 on a une 260 20
environ de plus en plus
de jeunes avec un collègue
mais nenê est la nouvelle étoile à une
très longue histoire au départ dix
neuvième siècle si je me trompe pas le
but était d'aider les mères célibataires
à aller travailler en ouvrant des places
de crèches la garde d'enfant c'est
souvent entre un frein à l'emploi donc
ça reste encore à prêts à l'emploi pour
les mères célibataires
d'autant plus que celle que nous
atteignons nous rencontrent également
des problématiques d'hébergement elles
sont hébergées dans des centres
d'hébergement fois chr ont fait agira
sous d'autres lieux et se pose la
problématique vingt deux premiers et
nous risquons n'a pas une place en
crèche et pop était vide et pouvoir
avoir le service des nourrices
indépendante c'est très compliqué au
niveau financier pour le frein à
l'emploi évidemment et clarisse gorce
comment vous accompagnez justement le
l'entrée dans l'emploi le retour à
l'emploi de manière générale et puis
notamment les femmes que vous
accompagner alors bon c'est vrai qu on
est donc on a un club d'entreprises a
donc les entreprises ont un rôle
important donc pas dans l'emploi je le
découpe suite en premier rendez-vous non
on ne trouvera pas d'accord vous le
trouverez bien tout seul mais vrai cette
connexion les personnes minces
progresser donc à public d'un regard de
l'accident ce big surtout donc déjà la
reconstruction la rencontre avec des
professionnels pour confirmer leur
projet professionnel
voilà beaucoup pour congé de
reconversion c'est ce que ça chez
l'étudiant n'a réagi on est vraiment sur
des rencontres avec des professionnels
et du parrainage un groupe edison phare
depuis 21 ans chez face et un salariés
en poste pris tous les quinze jours va
recevoir cette personne avait un trouble
accompagné par rapport à ses besoins
c'est parce que j'ai ce que c'est un
positionnement est ce que c'est des
chiffrages d'offres voilà tous les
publics de 18 à 62 ans quels que soient
libres et simplement la personne peut
vraiment motivé khune et qui va saveurs
de quiz et pourrait donner pour
construire un projet vraiment clair et
pouvoir se poursuivre avec un bon outil
alors à fait pas du 8 mars souvent les
communes se mobilisent vous propose
maintenant d'écouter joséphine comme
malte verger la mère de plaisir nous
fait le point sur ce mois consacré à la
question mis en place par la ville
[Musique]
à moi c'est presque pas suffisant par
rapport à toutes les actions aujourd'hui
et tout ce que l'on ressent aujourd'hui
sur la société ce sentiment d'insécurité
ce sentiment d'inégalité également je
pense que aujourd'hui il faut bien
consacrer un mois entier pour ce genre
de choses
[Musique]
la programmation s'adresse bien sûr à
toutes les femmes on commence aussi je
dirais à solliciter auprès des collèges
même au niveau je dirais des écoles
élémentaires puisqu'on commence apparaît
aussi de tous ces sujets là haut niveau
je dirais des enfants et je dirais aussi
auprès de ces messieurs puisque
aujourd'hui je considère que la société
doit être sensible à ces sujets là
des parties zen avec des soins des mains
avec des toute une série d'actions est
tourné vers elle et puis nous aurons
aussi des autrices qui vont venir
puisqu'on dit hauteur mais on dit aussi
aux tristes qui vont venir travailler
avec nous sur sur le travail aussi de
l'égalité femmes hommes au niveau du
sport puisque le rugby le foot comme je
vous le disais travailler avec nous et
puis il y aura des conférences et puis
aussi des petits déjeuners où nous
allons pouvoir échanger avec la
population
les partenaires bien sûr ce sens tous
les services de l'asile puisqu'on
travaille aussi bien avec les quartiers
un politique de la ville avec les femmes
des quartiers mais également avec nos
seniors dans la maison rosso et avec
toutes les associations qui sont
partenaires de nos actions par exemple
je donne un exemple c'est le football
club de plaisir le flop puisque nous
avons aujourd'hui des équipes féminines
qui travaillent avec nous ce sont toutes
ces actions que nous mettons en place
pour que au sein des agents de la
collectivité nous puissions avoir un
travail
égalitaire et de reconnaissance
égalitaire des femmes par rapport aux
hommes
nous avons une autre commune de saint
quentin en yvelines avec nous ce soir
assez guyancourt avec bénédicte hélico
in la ville met en place depuis
plusieurs années le temps des femmes qui
a évolué
oui
alors oui ça fait aller
tout à fait ça fait plus de dix ans que
nous avions ce qu'on appelle le temps
des femmes
et nous avons fait une belle évolution
ces dernières années en effet je pense
que le 8 mars c'est un moment important
mais le mois de mars c'était aussi un
moment important et une étape
supplémentaire c'est lui en course
engagée nous avons signé la charte de
l'égalité n'est la charte en septembre
et c'est un engagement plus fort puisque
collective de ce match et s'engager à
cette
thématique mais ces chartes elle vous
oblige je crois à respecter des règles
elles vous renforcez votre engagement
aussi vous donner un fil conducteur pour
mieux respecter cette égalité que vous
souhaitez mettre en place elle elle
reste elle
les actions les banques ont les menait
déjà mis en examen dans tous les
secteurs secteur de l'enfance secteur de
la jeunesse secteur culturel le point
entre autres mais aussi sur le travail
sur les violences et ça c'est important
tous ces thématiques soient revalorisés
au niveau d'une collectivité
en fait c'est le problème de l'égalité
c'est le problème de tous tout homme
mais aussi des collectivités et cette
signature est notable que
toutes les communautés les coller ville
et je pense que c'est important d'avoir
passé cette attaque alors on a créé un
nouveau logo égalité et on a posté
l'article toujours notre part et est ce
que la programmation culturelle et c'est
vrai il ya un élément de beaux qu'on a
déjà exploité depuis deux ans c'est le
matinal
c'est ont conclu radio mada magic woman
permettrait c'est une grosse partie où
depuis plusieurs années vous travaillé
dessus à guyancourt
il ya une notion moins joyeuse du côté
du droit des femmes c'est la sécurité en
2020 sans deux femmes ont été tuées par
leur partenaire ou ex partenaire 82% des
morts au sein du couple sont des femmes
mairieen m j'aime bien ennjimi pardon la
nouvelle étoile dont vous êtes la
directrice est opératrice d'un nouvel
accueil à versailles pourquoi
alors oui la nouvelle étoile quand je
disais tout à l'heure et a été créé en
depuis le 19e siècle à la campagne la
femme et l'enfant pour leur permettre
l'autonomie et leur permettre
effectivement de retrouver une place
dans la société et nous avons avancé sur
nos projets et nous accueillons des
femmes victimes de violence dans le
cadre de les perdre et on se rend compte
effectivement que bon il faut un travail
en amont avant que la femme arrive à
l'extrême de la situation il est si les
arrivants l'urgence dans l'hébergement
et nous avons réfléchi sur une ouverture
d'un accueil de jour pour faits de
violence pour pouvoir mener aussi tout
ce travail qui peut se faire à
l'extérieur
qui est l'accueil de jour a été inauguré
hier à la journée des droits des femmes
est on car à vis de l'ouvrir il se
trouve à versailles il accueillera
toutes les femmes qui sont victimes de
violence qui peuvent trouver une petite
maison chaleureuse avec les équipements
on a essayé de faire en sorte ce soir le
plus accueillant possible le moins
institutionnalisée aussi pour que ça
passe voilà pour ce sens bien dedans
qu'est la maman il en force semble dans
et l'accompagnement qu'il est mise en
place est d'abord accueillir accueillir
la personne un endroit sécurisé et
sécurisant les côtés d'écouté selon ses
désirs sa temporalité et les mots
qu'elle a besoin de mettre lakitu
qu'elle va nous opposer et puis ensuite
la poignée guinée qu'elle l'accompagné
dans ses démarches dans le processus de
sortie de violences à sa place des
rendez vous à faire à mesure travailler
avec elle la séparation ainsi parfois il
nécessaire pour qu'elle puisse sortir de
la violence l'accompagner au niveau
administratif pour qu'elle puisse
préserver ces documents parce qu'on perd
mais la domiciliation et on a une
bagagerie qu'elle puisse préserver aussi
leurs documents et leurs effets
personnels et surtout aussi prendre soin
d'elle dans une salle qu'on appelle la
salle des tic et pierre menât
comprennent aussi physiquement à
l'extérieur s'il ya besoin d'accompagner
au commissariat pour le dépôt de
plaintes éventuellement dans les rendez
vous n'était pour l'allergie de
pouvoir faire constater les violences
est resté à côté d'elle jusqu'au moment
où on l'a sécurisé il a écrit passera le
relais aux collègues ont travailleurs
sociaux qu'ils sont chargés de
l'accompagnement dans le cadre des pad
ou dans une structure d'hébergement qui
va la protéger et qui va continuer si ce
qu'on fait d'ailleurs dans notre cnrs et
puis ça se travaille là ça peut durer un
certain temps c'est à dire avant sénat
enfin dans le processus de sortie de
violence avec les femmes qui notamment
donc ses pions on imagine c'est une bien
sûr une démarche qui est toujours très
difficile si la faire bien parfois il
faut arriver à des des mesures beaucoup
plus drastiques alors carreaux notamment
le cidff est le référent départemental
des suivis tgd c'est le téléphone grave
danger et le bar le bracelet anti
rapprochement en 2017 vous avez
accompagné près de 1500 yvelinoise
victimes de violences conjugales c'est
un chiffre énorme elles ont droit d'être
protégé
oui enfin que les chiffres de 2009 mais
21 voilà on a les mêmes mais même chine
près en a même une explosion des
demandes de téléphone de leurs revenus
tu maintenant on en a 40 sur le
département et qu'on ait solidité
calment finalement pour rencontrer des
femmes bénéficient de ce dispositif
donc c'est effectivement que
de protection qui sont vraiment ou à des
femmes qui sont en situation de grand
danger donc clairement la donne et
menacé on peut pas donner des téléphones
à toutes les victimes de l'encadrement
pas beaucoup mais voilà il ya vraiment
des populations manger elle promeut la
pratique un petit positif de protection
que vous venez d'arriver bien au chaud
que vous veniez de la lave des
féminicides effectivement et d'éducation
oui on vous entend il ya des droits qui
sont plus difficiles j'imagine qu'ils
sont qui peuvent atteindre attendre
s'ils ne sont pas elles sont pas
protégés par don de ses droits ça peut
devenir dangereux pour les femmes vous
avez des problématiques tout les cas
différente elles seront jeunes aussi
beaucoup il ya un d'un droit qui
correspond à un autre j'imagine que vous
travaillez tout en collaboration sur le
territoire des civils vous vous
connaissez toutes à peu près peut-être
madame gorce à qui j'ai moins donner la
parole jusqu'à présent oui bah c'est
vrai que déjà nous on est financé pour
une bonne partie par le département dont
les territoires d'action sociale nous
aurions beaucoup le cidff sert à ça peut
fonctionner en effet
avec nous on travaille avec un des pôles
emploi ligne sur local voilà
que on vient apporter une
complémentarité avec la connexion à
l'entreprise et donc voilà on arriva à
une période grave à l'emploi mais à la
reprise de confiance et c'est vrai qu'on
oriente aussi facilement vers des
structures comme les cas en effet de
violence ou pour les cas de
vraiment un travail social à faire avant
voilà on est vraiment on est toujours
sur une étape du corps de la personne
quelle que soit l'organisme nous
l'envoie à peut-être coûté que de devoir
chercher des informations autour de ces
droits il faut sensibiliser on entendait
madame le maire de plaisir tout à
l'heure madame à l'icône qui nous il en
a présenté aussi alors qu'aaron
notamment dans vos missions géant
martyrs avec vous vous allez à la
rencontre des jeunes pour les prévenir
des comportements sexistes et violent
oui effectivement pas d'égalité
faible sensibilité
thématique là on intervient au dernier
pour réfléchir avec lui durant les
représentations dont esterino voilà moi
les choses
donc c'est intéressement et pour les
jeunes et puis voilà d'échanger sur ce
penalty fiasco oui il ya encore beaucoup
de stéréotypes
encore avec des instructions
mais est-ce que vous dans vos missions
vous disiez vous accompagner les femmes
est-ce que elles sont encore victimes de
préjugés ou elle même coincé par des
préjugés qui font qu'elles ne sont pas
au courant des droits auxquels elles
peuvent avoir droit justement
je rejoins complètement ce que madame
carreaux vient de dire c'est vrai que
c'est une question c'est une question
d'éducation et de changement de
mentalité de la société en général on le
retrouve chez les femmes mais on le
retrouve aussi à l'extérieur et il hier
nous avons fait un atelier débat avec
les dames qui sont hébergés chez vous
ils n'iront leur a demandé de nous dire
quelle est la place de la femme dans
cinq boucles simple la société
aujourd'hui et on leur a donné la parole
sans pour autant
intervenir et donner leur vision des
choses et on a été surprise
effectivement je vous donne juste un
exemple pour une dame qui nous a parlé
du viol domestique qu'elle ne
déterminait pas comme maintenant un axe
de violence vis-à-vis d'elle donc une
autre new river pour la contraception et
ben je vais voir avec mon mari pour voir
si je peux effectivement dépassées c'est
pour vous dire
comment voilà encore beaucoup de travail
à faire au niveau de la société et au
niveau de même au niveau de l'éducation
par rapport aux jeunes pour la santé les
attaquent pour les générations à venir
les femmes nous avons on essaye de
travailler avec elle pour les
sensibilités les ouvrir et que les
informer sur les droits et les
accompagner pour qu'elles puissent
solliciter soit le cdf soit les autres
associations une petite île d informer
notamment l'apa et mixé verra surtout ce
qui montre un petit pot mais la
génération à venir on n'en a pas il ya
encore du travail j'ai juste terminée on
est un peu pris prise par le don ce que
nous sommes toutes des femmes ce soir
sur l'émission j'ai que der thiam n'est
que vous madame alliés comme vous en
avez vite fait parler tout à l'heure
puisque la ferme de bel ébat à lancer un
réseau coopératif s'est fait plusieurs
années que je travaille autour du
matrimoine on parlait des droits du
futur mais avec le matrimoine vous
remettez en place aussi tout ce qu'il a
eu avant c'est quoi le patrimoine le
made in one c'est remettre en place la
part des femmes dans la vie quotidienne
dans la culture est justement pour
casser les stéréotypes il faut pas
oublier qu'elle est 50% bhl la
population du mal monté et que c'est
important qu'elles puissent au travers
de l'histoire des classiques de la
musique elle puisse rejaillir 4 que
souvent elles ont été oubliés et donc on
va vous présenter sur nausées nos
services culturels deux événements entre
autres musical qui s'appelle le piano
révolutionnaire est en effet avec l'aide
de mon show
complètement inexistant mais une des
plus grande pianiste de l'époque et qui
aujourd'hui donc en partie avec le tient
qu'à saint-quentin va pouvoir revivre à
l'auditorium très prochainement le
toulouse le 17 mai et puis aussi
se poser la question si souvent dans nos
autres hills dans l'eau
novatrice
n'était pas à l'ombre de leur mari ou
d'horreur de leurs frais
voilà
je suis obligé de vous couper le temps
file vraiment trop vite je vous remercie
tout les 4 d'avoir
accepté notre invitation tout au long de
l'émission les sites internet les
numéros un nécessaire pour se renseigner
auprès de ces pour avoir ses droits sont
apparus n'hésitez pas à les contacter si
vous avez des questions merci à nos
téléspectateurs nous avoir suivis vous
l'avez bien compris le statut de société
est maintenant terminée on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro
[Musique]